Hey, dog.
What'd you get up
to this weekend, though, dog?
Ah, you know me, man.
Got up all up
in that Redbox.
- Ah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah?
- Yeah.
- You know who's good, though?
- Who that, dog?
Robert Downeys Juniors.
Robert Downeys Juniors,
though, dog? Which one?
- Which one?
- Tony Starks, dog.
Tony Starks! Yeah, man.
- Tony Starks. Iron Mans.
- Yo.
That man be building
his own suit and everything
and getting all witty
with Pepper Pottsies.
Yeah, yeah. Yo, yo, my man's got
a glowing heart in that one.
(both)
Wan, wan, wan.
You give that [bleep] a statue
for that alone.
- That's right there, man.
- Whoo!
Definitely, dog, yo,
but yo,
another thing
about RD Squared real quick?
- Go to it.
- Sherlocky Holmes.
Sherlocky Holmesies.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait.
When Sherlocksy Holmes
is in that pit
and he's fighting that dude.
Yeah, and he fighting
that dude.
And then all of a sudden
in his mind
he made everything
go in slow motion.
[British accent] "I've got to
do this, and I got to do this,
and then statistically
I should do this."
And then the cane,
and then he went back
to real-life speed,
and he did it.
[overlapping chatter
and shouting]
What?
That was my jam.
- That was my jam right there.
- That was my jam.
He knew what was going
to happen using statistics!
Yo, and then remember
that one scene
where he woke up in
his neighbor's daughter's bed,
and he was all on drugs
and [bleep]?
- Oh, yeah!
- Yo.
No, no, that was RD Squared in
real life, though, right there.
It was. It was.
That was real life, though.
He was good in that one, though.
He was good.
- He was good in that one.
- That was very realistic, yup.
You know who else is good,
though, dog?
- Who, who, who, who, who?
- Vally Kilmers.
Oh, we talking 'bout
Vally Kilmers right now.
We talking 'bout Vally Kilmers
right now, dog.
Which one? Which one?
Which one?
Which one? Oh, you know,
Vally Kilmers in Tombstones.
Oh, what?
[imitating hooves clopping]
What?
Come on, man.
- [imitates whipping]
- [imitates horse neighing]
That's my [bleep] right there.
Doccy Hollidays, dog?
Oh, my God.
My man's talking about...
[inhales and exhales]
"I'll be your huckleberry."
Ooh, and they was up
in that O.K. Corral.
- Talking about--
- Oh, the shootout?
[imitating gunshots]
- Earps. Earps. Earps. Earps.
- Buck. Buck.
Okay. Okay.
Oh, you ain't okay.
Ha ha!
- That's my jam right there.
- That's my jam.
But what about my boy Vally
Kilmers in Willows, though?
Oh.
What about Vally Kilmers
in that Willows, though, right?
Vally Kilmers in that Willows,
dog, yo!
When he was Madmartigans
and they was
in that medieval toboggan.
Talking about--
[imitating sledding
and adventure music]
What?
[both imitating sword fighting]
And the little leprechaun
talking about, "You are great."
He was
magically delicious, dog!
- Magically delicious, dog.
- That was my jam.
Oh, but what about Val Kilmers
in The Saints? What?
Oh, Vally Kilmers
in The Saint.
Vally Kilmers in The Saint,
though, what?
When my man--
my man was like--
And--and then--
and then he--
and then he was like--he--
I-I didn't see that one.
Just the cover
looked enticing.
Yo, yo, you know
what I'm realizing right now
for the first time?
What's that, dog?
It's like if there was a graph
of RD Square...
- Yeah, a graph.
- And Vally Kilmers' careers...
Yeah, yeah.
RD Square
would start down here.
Right, and Vally Kilmers
would be starting right up here.
And RD Square would get
this trajectory going.
Right, and then Vally Kilmers
be on this trajectory
- right here like this, right?
- And they just making movies.
They just making movies.
Making movies.
Getting a little crazy.
Just doing a little drugs.
Just getting a little bit--
Yup, doing crazy.
Making--still making movies.
And then they meet
at this point.
In the same movie.
Which is why the best movie
of all time is--
- Kiss Kiss--
- Bang Bang.
(both)
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
is my [bleep]!